samstagfrüh in ashraf einem der ältesten
viertel beruf in dieser mini wohnung auf
zwölf quadratmetern planen vier freunde
den sturz des politischen systems das
hat ein bisschen was von bastelstunde
und fiel von revolution die worte auf
dem transparent sind deutlich zeit zu
gehen ihr politik zuhälter steht da in
fetten lettern auf arabisch seit
vergangenem oktober fordern wir die
abschaffung des gesamten systems nicht
nur des premiers oder andere
einzelpersonen das ganze regime vom
präsidenten bis zum kleinsten
parteimitarbeiter alle sind korrupt alle
müssen weg besuch nahm ist 24 jahre alt
studiert biochemie ihre wut auf die
politiker ist die einer ganzen
generation
irland werde vom religiösen klüngel
regiert sagt sie der libanon sei zur
beute geworden von politikern denen die
bürger egal sein sie sind bereit in den
kampf zu ziehen
also wir haben hier unsere schutzbrillen
für die augen
und diese dinger gasmasken falls sie mit
tränengas auf uns schießen
wie wehrt man sich gegen eine regierung
die so fahrlässig mit dem leben ihrer
bürger umgeht wir dürfen am ort der
explosion drehen was genau ist hier
passiert vor sechs wochen völlig unklar
nach wie vor zwei dutzend verhaftungen
aber keine details dafür ein neuer brand
erst vergangene woche wie tief der
schmerz sitzt kann man sich anhören von
den menschen die neben anwohnern nun ihr
amery und ihr sohn haben gerade so
überlebt das sind unsere sachen aus der
wohnung wir haben sie herr ausgeräumt
weil die decke eingestürzt ist vieles
ist kaputt vor allem in meinem zimmer
wenig hilfe allein gelassen nach der
katastrophe so fühlen sie sich der
kleine mahmud sei traumatisiert erzählen
sie uns ich bleibe im libanon weil meine
familie hier ist aber wenn man sich die
situation des landes ansieht müssten wir
eigentlich alle gehen
er wusste davon
sie meinen den sprengstoff im hafen und
libanons christlichen präsidenten
michael a wenn du ein echter führer bis
kommen hier her zu uns zu deinem volk
aber sie meinen auch den schiitischen
hisbollah chef hassan nasrallah und alle
anderen politiker
laura heißt revolution
[Applaus]
auch wo es tun und ihre freunde sind
inzwischen angekommen mit ihrem plakat
wir wissen dass das gesamte system
kriminell ist sie können sich ja nicht
selbst dazu bekennen wir sagen dass sie
es sind
und so ziehen sie los durch die halbe
stadt bei 35 grad
die atmosphäre angespannt die
übergangsregierung bringt nicht die
polizei sondern die armee in stellung es
wird nicht mehr verhandelt auf den
straßen von geben
die soldaten haben uns das plakat
abgenommen sie haben meine freundin
geschlagen so steht es um die freie
meinungsäußerung im libanon
der staat tritt einschüchternd auf
wer eigentlich hat die macht im libanon
in diesem land in dem sie zwischen
christen sunniten schiiten drusen und
anderen aufgeteilt wird manche sagen nur
eine einzige gruppierung die die an
verstorbene iranische topmilitärs
erinnert und an ihre märtyrer hisbollah
die schiitische miliz die nicht nur
schwer bewaffnet sondern auch tief
verwurzelt ist im alltag auf dieser
station haben wir acht zimmer für
korrekt patienten ein hisbollah
krankenhaus in beirut corona macht es
möglich pr für die eigene sache wie
solar hat die klinik gekauft und
betreibt jetzt hier corona kampf der
bereiche unten ist eine grüne zone also
hier ist alles sicher
dort oben können sie verschlossene türen
so dass die patienten ihr stockwerk
nicht verlassen die solar ist im libanon
omnipräsent und deshalb ist es teheran
auch die gruppe weiß ihren einfluss
stets zu vergrößern besonders in
krisenzeiten
wir behandeln hier alle gleich diese
klinik kümmert sich nicht nur um die
liebten oder ist polar angehörige
sie steht allen menschen zur verfügung
hisbollah arbeitet für das ganze land
mit pipetten baut die hisbollah ihren
einfluss zurzeit aus sie ist der wahre
machtfaktor im land nur wenige libanesen
aber trauen sich das deutlich
auszusprechen
er tut es vor ort nach sumi
selfmade-milliardär ein mann
oppositionspartei im parlament in der
arabischen welt eine instanz er weiß was
hinter den kulissen passiert am ende des
tages wenn es ein vakuum gibt dann wird
derjenige das sagen haben der über die
waffengewalt verfolgt und das war damals
nur die hisbollah
also wenn man sagt hisbollah ist ein
staat im staat hisbollah kontrolliert
jeden einzelnen teil der regierung die
demonstranten wissen dass sie mächtige
feinde haben heute aber sind es die
unterstützer des präsidenten die zur
gegendemo angetreten sind
es fallen warnschüsse
es gibt verletzte
der kampf gegen ein regierungssystem mit
einer schatten macht wird heute nicht
entschieden
eine scheller und ich will gar nicht
präsident nennen er hat uns zum dialog
eingeladen aber er will gar nicht zu
hören
er hat uns die armee und die
spezialkräfte geschickt das sind leute
aus dem volk und so steht jetzt hier das
volk dem volk gegenüber
sie hängen auch heute wie der symbolisch
die galgenstricke auf wollen ein zeichen
setzen in ihrem frust was tun und ihre
freunde wissen am anfang einer
revolution ist ihr ausgang immer
ungewiss